I just gotta drive it it's okay I don't
want to do that forever you know that's
okay you won't I know I won't but it's
like I don't know it weighs on you angle
to go well what do you like that's the
thing man I don't I don't know sure you
do what do you do on the weekends man a
little bit so apply to 5 000 jobs
fantastic crypto jobs 100 when you get
home instead of spending your time
dwelling about job or doing to
escape it by playing video games or
hanging out or watching Netflix spend
those two hours put on your favorite
music and apply to 17 crypto jobs that
are remote let's go for it just go for
it most people have comfort in
complaining and dwelling and worrying
you need to get comfort in actually
going at it I hear you